Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're hanging out with
Chance the Rapper right here.
And we're about to play
"Hey, Robot."
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, Robot ♪
-All right.
Now, here's how this works.
This is based on the real board
game "Hey, Robot"
that you can play at home.
It's like the classic game
Password,
but your partner
is a smart speaker.
Okay, so first, I'll pick a card
with a word on it,
and then, we'll take turns
asking a question
to get the speaker to say that
word somewhere in it's answer.
If it does, you get a point.
All right, I'll go first.
-Okay.
I have to get it to say giraffe.
Okay.
-Good luck.
-Hmm.
Alexa, what is an animal
with a tall neck?
-Here's something
I found on the web.
According to AwesomePlanet.com,
giraffes are the tallest
of all land animals.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
You see what I'm saying, dude?
-I didn't know you can use it
like that? That's awesome.
-I'm a pro. I'm a pro at this.
All right, here you go.
You're up.
-Alright, here we go.
Um...okay.
Tongs.
Have to get her to say tongs.
-Tongs.
-Alright, uh...
Oh, Jesus. Uh...
Hey, Alexa.
What are the utensils
that you use to grab food?
-Sorry, I don't have
an answer.
-[ Shouts ]
-Hold on, hold on.
Let's try -- Let's just hear it.
Alexa, what are the utensils
you use to grab food?
-Here's something I found
on the web.
According to wiseandchic.com,
tongs are kitchen utensils.
[ Bell dings ]
-Thanks, Jimmy!
-Yeah, dude. That was good.
-You're not competitive at all.
-Oh, not at all.
-I love this.
Here we go.
Boardwalk.
[ Laughter ]
-Alexa, what is the name
of The Drifters' hit
"Under the..."
-I missed something.
-Yeah, me too.
Yeah, I missed something, too.
-Hmm. I don't know that.
-Yeah, I know. Yeah.
Alright, you go.
-Uh, hey, Alexa.
What's that show
that has Steve Buscemi on it?
-I know about 81 Steve Buscemi
TV shows,
including "Rick and Morty,"
"The Simpsons," "The Sopranos,"
"Boardwalk Empire."
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's do one more? [ Laughs ]
Let's do one more.
-Let's do one more.
That was great.
All right. Here we go.
This is for you.
You've got to get this.
-Ah, okay.
-Deep dish pizza.
That's a Chicago staple.
-Okay.
Uh, Alexa, what is Chicago's
famous cultural dish?
-Here's something I found
on the web.
According to CNBC.com,
Chicago is known
for its iconic Italian-inspired
deep dish pizza.
[ Bell dings ]
-Come on, now!
That's a pro!
That is a pro right there.
Chance the Rapper,
"Star Line Gallery"
will be out later this year.
He's performing for us later
in the show.
We'll be back with the cast
of "Reservation Dogs."
Stick around, everybody.